When Steve Jobs died in 2011, his admirers
paid tribute around the world.
This kind of turnout was usually reserved
for rock stars, not a CEO.
Yet this age arguably belongs to those who
build the future.
According to the Forbes list of the richest
people in the world in 2021, 7 out of the
top 10 made their fortune in engineering.
Amazon’s Jeff Bezos.
Tesla and SpaceX’s Elon Musk.
Microsoft’s Bill Gates.
Facebook's Mark Zuckerberg.
Oracle’s Larry Ellison.
Google’s Larry Page and Sergey Brin.
It’s hard to think of an engineer from the
seventies who was super well-known.
Yet today’s engineers are household names
whether we love’em or love to hate’em.
Musk even guest-hosted Saturday Night Live
which is usually reserved for famous actors
and artists.
He’s a new kind of celebrity with such a
huge Twitter following that he’s a walking
advertisement for Tesla.
In fact, Tesla doesn’t spend money on advertising
which I talked about in another video.
So, how did engineers become cool?
They used to be known for building public
infrastructure like bridges and dams.
Necessary for any functioning society but
not something that would normally attract
crowds.
Then, Jobs came along.
He didn’t have a technical background but he
had his hands in everything at Apple including
engineering.
The world changed when he put the internet
in everyone’s pocket with the introduction
of the iPhone in 2007.
The late Apple CEO built a following by creating
personal inventions that excited people.
Since then, engineers have continued to create
products that are in your personal space - be
it a smartwatch or social media - which has
in turn made them famous.
And the appetite for such products is only
growing.
Engineers are expected to experience a 3 percent
job growth in a decade which is on par with
average while the demand for software developers
is predicted to soar 22%.
They’re the ones responsible for writing
and designing code to develop apps.
In other words, creating the products we crave.
An increasing number of people are choosing
the profession.
In India, 30% of students pursued a degree
in STEM: science, technology, engineering,
and mathematics which produced almost 2.7
million graduates in 2018.
Where I live, in Canada, enrollment in math,
computer, and information sciences has increased
47% comparing a recent academic year to an
earlier one.
In a previous video, I mentioned that engineering
degrees are now more common than MBA degrees
amongst the world’s top-performing CEOs
which makes sense given some of the biggest
companies are tech giants.
There’s also the belief that engineers rise
to the top because they’re good problem
solvers.
Google’s former chief financial officer
Patrick Pichette once pointed out that “Google
is really an engineering company, with all
these computer scientists that see the world
as a completely broken place.”
Engineers try to solve the most pressing issues
of the day using technology.
Musk is a self-taught engineer who wants to
reduce pollution with his electric vehicles
and is confident the century-long dominance
of the internal combustion engine - otherwise
known as “ICE” is coming to a close.
Well, I don’t think there will be an ICE industry
long-term.
There are still, like, some steam engines made somewhere but, like, they're just,
basically, sort of,  quirky collector's items.
That will be the future of the internal combustion
engine (ICE) car.
At the same time, people like him have warned
of a dark side to technology.
He believes super-intelligent machines could
pose a threat to humanity and has called for
government oversight of artificial intelligence, fearing
AI will surpass humans in intelligence in
the way we outsmart cats.
Smart machines are expected to eliminate many
human jobs.
FedEx has now teamed up with a robotics company
to test out autonomous delivery vehicles.
Amazon runs cashier-less grocery stores and
wants to deliver packages by drone in under
30 minutes.
The World Economic Forum says the rise of
automation will result in a loss of 85 million
jobs by 2025 yet in the same breath adds
97 million new jobs will be created such as
AI and machine learning specialists and data
analysts.
There’s also the argument that future technology
will redefine the meaning of the traditional
workweek.
More than 100 years ago, people worked
70 hours a week on average.
With the industrial revolution and labor laws,
it’s now down to about 35 hours.
The former head of British Petroleum, Lord
John Browne, remarked: “Why do we then define
work as a 35-hour week?
Why can’t it be 17-and-a-half?”
Behind these forces of societal change are
engineers who dream big.
Bezos’ space venture Blue Origin has dreamt
up space colonies straight out of seventies
science fiction.
Though the plan hasn’t won over a fellow
billionaire who has a different vision of
humanity in space.
Musk’s SpaceX expects Mars to be colonized
by a constant flow of humans traveling aboard
Starships.
So long as we have a desire for new adventures
and new things, engineers will continue to
build the future and enjoy all the attention
that comes along with it.
At the core of an engineer is exceptional
skill and ability.
If you’d like to brush up on your math or
computer science skills or you simply want
to learn more about how our world works, my
sponsor Brilliant can help and it’s FREE to sign up.
Brilliant is a website and app built off the
principle of learning while doing.
You simply pick a course and jump right in.
One of my favorites is the logic courses.
If you’re feeling stuck on a problem, you
can read the explanations to find out more.
Brilliant has something for everybody. Besides
the math, science, and computer science courses,
you can even dive into cutting-edge topics
like Cryptocurrency.
If you'd like to join me and a community of
8 million learners and educators, click the
link in my description or visit: brilliant.org/newsthink.
The first 200 people to use my link will get
20% off the Premium subscription which gives
you unlimited access to all the courses.
For Newsthink, I’m Cindy Pom